welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley hey everybody out there and
welcome back to everybody's favorite new
podcast this is are you garbage to show
what we sit down with your favorite
comedians and find out they grew up
classy or if they're complete trash I'm
your holy coming at you on a beautiful
day hear from the rubber room at gasps
digital studios and speaking of crazy
how about that deal promo code a ygf
signup today save a dollar 50 on the
subscription and a 14-day free trial
my co-host coming at you right next to
me pal he's the brains behind the
operation let me tell you something
folks the next time you reach for a best
pal do yourself a favor make it a Kippy
Kevin James Ryan everybody hey gang
what's up everybody thanks so much for
tuning in happy to be here a little bit
of housekeeping shot everybody who's
been reading reviewing subscribing on
iTunes we appreciate it we're still on
the top 200 thank you very much yes sir
if you haven't already please go rate
review subscribe tell a [ __ ] friend
let's get this thing [ __ ] cookin I
hear you Kippy I hear you and I like it
and I love it and I love our very
special guest that we have in studio
today highly demanded guest here Oh baby
ladies and gentlemen he is an actor a
writer director and of course a
podcaster some of his latest films
Shakespeare shitstorm bucket love
anonymous all available on Disney plus I
bet you've also seen him into practical
jokers all right he's the co-host the
realest realest podcast and of course
zac amico 'he's midnight spook show
ladies and gentlemen the big question of
what he's mine today is he garbage I say
a hard no and I've structured my
questions to prove my [ __ ] case
ladies and gentlemen give it up for the
one the only mr. sacker Mike Oh
everybody thank you so much for having
me gentlemen a big fan of the show and
I'm excited to be here
thankfully you buddy we are very happy
to have you here well we we have played
this mildly with Zach previously unreal
last podcast yes and we were shocked
stunned shocked out stunned at the
results to the line of questioning set
forth at a previous date there is a
dichotomy here yes remember yes I would
appear trashy but consider the people I
present myself with sure of course my
yeah I don't know you're a [ __ ] I
don't know how to place it because NYU
education why you did you graduate
yeah him why you alright well though not
real school doesn't matter slowly can't
even walk by and why you got the dorm
that's all accounts with me did you have
a lot did you have a card to get to the
cafeteria you're a college man as far as
I'm concerned on paper not only card the
end of the cafeteria at the time card to
get into the only chick-fil-a in New
York City it was a secret chick-fil-a at
the time in one of the NYU CAF
cafeterias that's a natural before we
knew they hated gays I'm sure it's gone
now yeah fully didn't get that in fact I
quarterly secret chick-fil-a in a
basement did you ever go back and use
the card to get into the cafeteria after
you graduate it though never that's a
real scumbag move oh yeah I think they
shut that down for a little bit I see
Kevin Ryan's awfully quiet I know
Thanksgiving dinner probably I think
with the computer chips now that the
cards have or I think they expire they
get you know when did you graduate
how 2009 2009 how old of a young man are
you
he's mine yeah I'm 32 yeah but it's also
like Jersey so that's a couple points
down I mean by the looks of you
aesthetically you're [ __ ] a hundred
percent Josh checking account with you I
can tell you that I'm asking for the
next teller if that's what we're getting
that but very educated very smart knows
a lot knows like I feel like you're very
smart
would you get on your SATs that's when
what I took most still sick
would you get 14 times what holy [ __ ]
I'll start calling you sir it's gotta be
a record for you garbage if you added up
all the guest testicles
it wouldn't equal 1400 yeah you're a
smart guy
all right so tell us though tell us how
you passed well I think that's also a
very garbage thing I can't read I can
[ __ ] my way through a lot of stuff
that he's an auditory learner because I
was an auditory learner my mom used to
say that all the time to like cover up
when I was flunking everything well he's
actually an auditory learner yeah no
he's not he's a [ __ ] idiot what are
you talking about it
he's a [ __ ] but give us the origin
story here cuz I don't know where did
you grow up how did you grow up give me
the whole thing okay Secaucus New Jersey
okay dad is a welder her family in an
apartment on top of his shop and it was
my grandpa's business that he took over
ok did you open the real estate of the
shot was like the but it was my dad
that's a smart move if you hone the shop
you stay up you ain't gotta pay rent
only one mortgage probably what pay
something you ten bills off when you're
a single guy maybe but not with the
family what do you mean he's getting
into the welding products and [ __ ] like
that who knows what's going on my dad
grew up in that house it was a
one-bedroom and it was my grandma
grandpa my dad and his four brothers is
it like in town or because when I think
of like getting any welding done it's
not like in like a neighborhood no yeah
no it's in the middle of a neighborhood
what it was a scene like neighborhood
not like a suburban suburban
neighborhood but like I guess like a
Main Street suburban neighborhood or
like awesome and off of the main street
yeah
not too big did marine welding a lot of
like I either did well hold on he did
marine welding yeah a lot of washes so
he's not some [ __ ] grease monkey
working on an old Ford that's that's
intelligent [ __ ] right you do a lot of
battleships out under water a lot of
water [ __ ] yeah see like Cuba Gooding
jr. soldier a lot of like pant eyes for
docks so the boats don't crash into the
dock yeah
that specialty probably made a good
living off of that yeah yeah and then my
dad's favorite thing is whenever we
drive around anywhere in Jersey is to
point out either him or my grandpa did
the railings I can't [ __ ] drive
through Philly with this guy like yeah
we did the ACO that's in me that's just
blue collar guard like an American
Pickers driving around for the forward
in the front yard
my dad would drive by the yeah it was
all supermarkets and like hot moon we
put a yo 10 foot cooling stack on the
top of that over though yeah it goes in
there he tries to act like he's got
clout you know I mean you know put the
eatin his dump holy [ __ ] man working on
battleship so that's government
contracts yeah he still doesn't know
what's your mom do
my mom was an art teacher at a Catholic
school when I was little si si
you guys don't [ __ ] know look at this
right right you don't really have to
have any accreditation or couple of
crayons and some baby Edwards flannels a
lady she's just a woman that that's that
sharp and wait so from what I'm here and
it was that the only property or only
house you guys had there was no summer
property earlier no well your old man
must be stacking cash away I think he
did okay
yeah I mean he's blond he's on wife
number I'm not sure but major
relationship number portraying yourself
I didn't know this alright how many
times has he been married I think he's
on I don't know if he's mad I don't know
that why he married that's gone you
didn't get invited to the wedding what
if I did not get invite I did not go to
my dad SEC did not get invited to my
dad's I got it I went to the party after
[Laughter]
close friends and fans which I what you
can come giving them know you which I
was given a name tag that I had to write
Paul's son on Oh what my god holy Sh way
why cuz no one knew me or where who I
was
everyone loose holy [ __ ] so you didn't
meet how many people are at this wedding
for what it was in the break room
probably 100 so what happened was my dad
left when I was like 13 ish wait left
it's his shop where'd he go
you sold the shop oh so you moved out of
there yeah moved out all right this is
where things get such a picture potatoes
this what he moved out 13 okay
so otherwise before that it's you and
you said he had a sister
no just me my mom with it's just you
your mom and your dad Wow all right so
up until then it was everything was
copacetic and that one day we're losing
the shop yeah well it might as I'm
selling the shop and he got a job at a
bigger fur like welding company hmm
where he was gonna be like one of the
head you know uh-huh welders and and
that just happened to be around the same
time they got to divorce yeah crazy
right wasn't a stipulation in this
consciously so uh he lived in sea-cocks
for a little while then he moved in with
his second wife okay where he lived he
was a welder as well as he was the
handyman for a town in upstate New
York's cemetery so he lived in the
cemetery in a house with his second wife
they have kids no did you go up there
and see him where you like living back
and forth no I met her like if I met her
five times that's probably an
exaggeration you never went up and hung
out the cemetery because that's where I
figured to get down that seems right in
your wheel yeah he got a little jesusí
with wife number two what's that he had
a little jesusí with wife number two
that's the worse when they get jesusí
because it came with the whole funeral
like the cemetery but the church was
there too maybe he's just like to keep
the job and he was like a little it was
kind of like the town Gomer pile okay
any old jesusí but then he broke that
huh
there was another one in between that I
don't talk about she's buried in an
unmarked grave
another one there's a whole everything
there's a whole other thing that I
thought that I don't know what what I
could say so I don't sure sure sure
got the date and now he's got number
three that he lives with and she's got
two kids okay but you grew up with your
mom yeah okay your mom get remarried at
all no really
so what did you guys move to just
another no you stayed in the house my
mom got the house what'd you do with the
shop underneath first it was a like an
accessory shop where they made really
[ __ ] and now it is a karate studio
should go back flat is your mom still
own it yeah really
oh that horse washed out she rents out
the shop and she still lives on the top
half holy [ __ ] pretty good that's got it
would so did you have friends in the
neighborhood and [ __ ] like that very few
I'd imagine I was in another junkyard
dogs indoor boy Wow and yeah so my dad
was a sober for a few years before we
got married
uh-huh the first thing my mom did when
they got divorced was get her bartending
license she and became a bartender
became his Borton know just became it
was literally doofy it was literally a
spike career yeah Wow damn after this
day my mom's a bartender and a hostess
at Olive Garden really yeah wait what
happened to the teaching job that was
only for a few years when I was a kid oh
I'm sorry I want to put that one in the
file that's a Olive Garden Olive Garden
yeah
did you go there and hang out with her
while she was working something I was
all there by that point I was like 14 15
did you go in and have a bite every once
in a while that's Bret's text-align
exact now she brought it home a lot but
I later found out she only got like 20%
like it was not worth taking it or it
was literally just makes a hundred owes
three hundred night it was not worth the
discount trying to keep the kid in
primavera that's crazy
so what would you say the childhood was
like growing up good middle class yeah
yeah do you still talk to your dad oh
yeah I uh we might have didn't talk
probably for about two years when I was
in like high school and then we wound up
getting along again real
good and real close and jinda are you
not close with his current wife they're
nice people in the hallway what's up
like the other day my wife said to me
something about like how's your
stepbrother and I was like I've never
called them that who's your stepbrother
my some douche named Jim yeah my dad my
dad's chickens two kids but not with not
his gal that's not your step that's real
trashy right there that's not your step
brother I wouldn't call him that
yeah that's a stranger that's all that
is that's not some guy getting in the
will that's what the [ __ ] yeah I helped
that my help my dad move into there your
mom got the house I helped my dad move
into the house the first time in there
and I never won again pan now they're
moving to a new house I think it's been
like five years you get help moving in
holy [ __ ]
but you obviously a good student did I
right yeah right got into NYU what other
schools did you get into there's only
one I applied to film and television for
me I did early whatever early access so
I I applied in like September okay yeah
and I got in and then I stopped giving a
[ __ ] about everything in high school I
stopped carrying a bag I just had like a
lunchbox once you got into NYU yeah cuz
I got in it I quit every club I was in
yeah no [ __ ] have to get out yeah I went
to degree in Chess Club yeah I quit
everything I love garden and it was
great holy [ __ ] and never went back
obviously after NYU no I would go I
lived at home for the summer for three
years okay
in between and I would be a I worked as
a janitor at my old high school all over
the summers wait a minute after you
graduated no no while I was at school
why you were in college that was my
summer job okay well you never there
when other students were there no huh no
just be summers and they would hire a
couple kids do like handyman [ __ ] like
repaint okay [ __ ] puke in the
lunchroom and you
kid you know that yeah amigo is that you
thought you were an NYU film school
really seems to be paying enough for you
cuz I don't know why but for some reason
at college I got financial aid then I
got a little bit of a grant to play
football but I start with still there we
go I was three days I was any reason to
hear some tales from Polk high my
shoulder still hurts a little bit listen
can I get an Advil for this knee no but
I took a job at the University so like
I'd be out there in the morning like
raking up leaves our people are walking
to class and [ __ ] with coveralls on the
whole nine yards who's real who's really
hurt the self-esteem with the ladies I'm
not gonna go to the stop hold on I gotta
[ __ ] uvv dog [ __ ] cleaned up all
right well that is a [ __ ] tale man
let's get into some more you garbage
questions here with our good pal zac
amico let's start out with the basics so
i can get a little bit of a picture of
this town this whole welding outfit how
was the apartment cool it would imagine
it would have to be cool it was a we
used to be a 1-bedroom that my
grandfather built an addition on the
back mm-hmm no doors so my room no door
just connected to the living room living
room my kitchen my parents room and like
a back room that was another bedroom
slash like video games computers and
[ __ ] in there okay with a deck on the
back that my dad built okay
but no doors so I grew up my whole life
till 18 I had never had a bedroom door
what was the wide jerk no pray to God no
one's awake Jesus Christ he said an
alarm for like 3:00 a.m. to wake up and
tell your roof that's like military dad
[ __ ] then take the doors off nobody
closes doors in my house after my dad
left my mom wouldn't sleep in their bed
for a few years so she slept on the
couch outside of where my room was so if
you want to talk tense
Iram I remember a night where I had a
mosquito bite and I'm scratching this
thing and by Bob caimans
screaming cuz she thought I was I swear
to God I got Skeeter bites I know you're
doing something you're not supposed to
be doing oh my god privacy by the skin
of your balls you got in and what you
thought you thought this guy was all
class meanwhile he's doing quiet jerks
what about alright so you mean give me a
picture of this town well his name of
the street that you grew up on Irving
Irving what place please
man a place is pretty classy you live on
a place places alright the circle just
to the record for the fans out there
circle would be the highest court isn't
too bad
courts not bad but that could be a
[ __ ] town house you know I mean I
could be next to the clubhouse on the
townhouse alright will you pick up weed
and [ __ ] if you live on a pike you
[ __ ] up
if you ever hunt [ __ ] something pike
you've made some bad real estate
investment I used to live on a way that
it depends yeah that's good looking at
you that's when you know you've made too
much [ __ ] your [ __ ] man what do you got
what was the name of the supermarket
sure you grew up the blue town Oh food
towns are kind of town sounds like a bad
band in the 90s it's that's where fully
wants a bite wait till I get my money
right live on cereal way down and then
if we were with my grandma shop right in
North Bergen Oh shop rights are classy
fresh produce quality deli doings nice
they cease always just right over it
shopping carts there's never like the
flyer or the circular floating around
the cards I gotta clean my home card out
I'm [ __ ] going somewhere else
listen I I was a [ __ ] car boy for
like [ __ ] two years attacked me like
you got to clean the cart so it was an
ACME in the middle of Secaucus yeah
Acme's dependent on where acnes and the
burbs are
in there with with the accent which
believe it or not I've dropped most of
mm-hmm
it's even called it the akka me that's a
Philly thing so going down to the akka
me I'm going to the akka me do you want
any luncheon meats then luncheon yeah
real trash luncheon meats from the akka
me the preferred is cold cuts that's
class no that's I don't like that either
it's lunch meat cold cuts sounds medical
or sanitary makes a hell of a roto
rotisserie chicken rotisserie chicken
from the supermarket Zack I'm gonna have
to wager here fan that's a pretty great
Buy yeah man can't beat their birth and
a chicken raising it killing it cooking
it shipping it what the fall for like
$5.99 in about 45 minutes because those
babies are young was a prepubescent they
don't got here have you ever worked at a
supermarket
no okay we've ever worked for a local
production company no interesting what
would he be like in Jersey
mmm-hmm weddings or anything like that
now be funny if you write your dad's
wedding because you were filming it was
it was Paul son and also the DJ know my
jobs were um janitor movie theater as
well as my uncle has a thumanns truck
and I would do the [ __ ] assume inch
like Boar's Head or like it's a couple
Stacy he's got a route yeah he's gonna
route routes are nice that's a real
Jersey tremens is pretty it's not boat
let's listen yeah it's not boards not
boys that okay few things are and so I
would work for him two days a week
but that was like 4:00 a.m. to 6 p.m.
doing a route from like Secaucus the
Carteret and the [ __ ] was going
to the Palio plant at 5:00 a.m. your
string cheese joint now getting
mozzarella curd for all the Guinea delis
we went to mozzarella curd I'm talking
in the pallets of curd every [ __ ] day
Palio is the best to and that's a
phenomenal have to double down word you
reaching for a string cheese
don't three yourself and I don't
string cheese what never did hi you're
out of your mind your string cheese guy
got big what about you dylan string
cheese there you go real question I'm
not saying they're a part or do you just
take bites out of it
wow you got weight how listen I don't
[ __ ] with them but you gotta be a
gentleman and pull it the [ __ ] apart if
you're a savage taking a bite out of a
string cheese
you're a [ __ ] jerk it'll start like
that yeah all right it'll I'll start
doing the nice things but by the end I'm
just [ __ ]
going right through down like a hot dog
[ __ ] Kobayashi go bully don't even
take the wrapper you open it up did the
wrapper and water all right I got all
right I got it I got one here what was
your first email address I think this is
a fan question too or your or your uh it
was a family email address renamed so
the first thing now was me my mom and
dad had one email address
nobody loves each other it was our first
initials and our the numbers on our
house okay shared an email so you I get
the vibe you were a big computer video
game guy no not really I mean he's an
indoor kid what were you doing in there
some video yes so n64 action playing
with this mosquito trying to put a
couple doors up a lot of activities dude
in the house no I mean just I was always
busy I wrestled I did play I just did a
ton of show you said indoor kid I
figured you were like in there
trying to keep the demons away playing
[ __ ] super mario brothers you are a
well-rounded guy I was the goal was
always to get into a good school so I
always did a lot of extracurricular [ __ ]
Wow good for I never thought about that
[ __ ] until [ __ ] like the last part of
my scene really you peg me as a guy who
gets out in front of things and really
you know really has a [ __ ] five-year
plan going you idiot
I don't know what was going all right
gang real quick reminder to today's
episode is brought to you by sheath
underwear it's the summertime it's hot
and sweaty out there and that's why you
need
sheath sheath is the softest most
comfortable boxer-brief that I have ever
worn I have a whole [ __ ] bag of them
in the trunk and I can't wait to get
home and slip into them
I know kippis a big fan oh yeah and
here's what makes sheath unique it's got
a pouch so you can separate your dick
from your balls
all right that is huge in the summer
time especially when you're outside
working out because I know my [ __ ]
apparatus sticks together like an old
piece of Bologna
yeah and with chief you don't got to
worry about that yeah it's it is awesome
oh my god some this week in the mail and
I haven't gotten out of them he won't
stop talking about now I'll for some of
you you don't you might not be
interested in separating your [ __ ]
man parts you should because once you
realize your balls aren't on your leg
it's a [ __ ] game changer I never knew
I needed my balls off of my leg but I do
that's clean living but even if you're
not if that uh if that for some odd
reason that doesn't interest you you can
still wear them like regular boxer
briefs and they're crazy comfortable the
links they're smooth there's psycho my
sexy underwear very soft yeah and they
look good if you can take you know if
you got a special lady or man in your
life you know what I mean show him a
derriere shot take some pics you know
what I mean you feel good it's good for
dick pants the underwear so go to sheath
underwear dot-com to get a pair of smart
underwear and if you use the code
garbage that's G a RB a GE you'll get 20
percent off your order 20 20 percent
babies to use damn whose code garbage ga
r ba GE you'll get 20 percent off your
order that sheath underwear comm promo
code garbage o get that sheet underwear
everybody all right guys let's take a
second to talk about today's sponsor
real paper yes please that's real paper
is here to make sure you never run out
of toilet paper ever again no more
emergency trips the store you're not
getting jammed up no more random napkins
tissues even during the pandemic real
has made sure that their subscribers
have toilet paper
they make incredibly soft three pop
three ply toilet paper delivered
straight to your door not only is real
super soft and
durable it's also made entirely of
sustainable bamboo Wow even reals
packaging is great for the environment
since they don't use any plastic
wrapping with reel you can pick and
choose when you want to get your
shipment so you'll never run out of
toilet paper again and I just got a
shipment in this week mm-hmm dude game
changer it's good stuff it's awesome
you know what's crazy you know what's
the best part about reel this is a
pretty cool thing for every roll of
toilet paper that you buy all right
every roll of toilet paper you buy real
helps people in need across the globe
have access to clean toilets cuz I
didn't know this I saw this on the on
the what's-his-name the Microsoft guy
gates yeah on his documentary 2.4
billion people around the world don't
even have access to a safe toilet ball
and real wants to bring that number down
to zero that's a pretty good company man
happy that's pretty great doing doing
good things for the world and you can
help just by wiping your ass with real
paper you're doing it anyway that's all
you got to do it feels fantastic I'm not
like idea it's a game-changer
so again do us a favor okay I want you
to go over to real paper comm that's our
EE L PA P er dot-com and if you use the
code garbage
jay-ar be a GE mm-hmm you'll get 10% off
a single purchase for your first
subscription order plus you're gonna get
free shipping in the US love that money
dude I tell you what man that's a pretty
solid company right there with a
fantastic product and that's real paper
calm and use the code garbage and be
sure to create an account for the code
to be activated you gotta create an
account but why wouldn't you want to
create an account for a great company
with a great product like that it's real
paper calm use promo code garbage do
some good for the world by wiping your
ass now it doesn't get any easier for
that I know everybody's sitting around
these days wondering how can I help out
the world how can I have with the world
you can go drop a deuce and you can use
some [ __ ] real paper do it alright
now let's get back to the show
have you ever smoked pot out of a soda
can oh yeah have you ever smoked crack
out of a soda can no okay
yes out of a soda can that's how they
did it I lived in North Carolina for a
little while and all the rich kids
that's how they would do it okay just
kidding mom your parents watch i watch
it on the big screen huh who I'm paying
for so no hear what they hear all right
what do you got Foley what do I got
I would like to know I say we got the
email address let me ask you this do you
think okay just to get a sense here do
you wash your hair before or after or
both at the beginning of the end of the
shower hmm
I realize this tells a lot about a
person beginning because then you use
the excess suds to help wash the rest of
you and they kind of go down you okay
some people would say that's not the
correct a reason but the correct answer
they would say that's your reasoning huh
what yeah what do you wouldn't people
say you should do it before because
that's all the although if you do it
after then you just cleaned your whole
body and your dirty hairs running down
okay I do it after a real piece of trees
what do you do
it depends well as you know I'm fighting
male pattern baldness so I have to let
my shampoos sit for a little bit so I
put it in and leave in situation I do
yes dissonance I gotta wait I gotta wait
till it starts burning before I take it
out so I put it in do the rest of the
body with a bar of soap no dish no no
rag like a gentleman okay you know and
then I wash out the hair plus I like the
smell of it cuz that's the last thing
that sticks you know interesting when do
you when if ever do you watch the bottom
of your feet only if there's an issue
everyone the bottom of my I would I
would have to have stepped in something
or have some kind of laceration or rash
or something on my foot to even get down
there dude this is like a shameful thing
I said we were at a comedy club it to me
yeah unless I was like you know [ __ ]
mom yeah stop at the knee I wasn't gonna
realize fully and I have temporary
relationships with our future
the b-trees might come and take one of
them jobs I try to keep him out of my
mind I don't know it's really a distant
relative if we have name tags on him
Foley's foot I was in mixed company and
they were all talking they're like yeah
so I like people every day right in if
you do this watch the bottom of their
feet like lift their foot up soap and
cloth or loofah whatever I gotta tell
you I haven't watched about my feet I
don't think in [ __ ] I don't think
ever that sounds like a recipe for
slipping - that's what I'm thinking
that's dangerous catch a slip and falls
it's a [ __ ] hazard slip on some
conditioner you're [ __ ] screwed did
you have any pets growing up yep you I
peg it was a weird pet guy Oh Oh money
on it dogs in the shop but they were
shop dogs didn't come upstairs loved a
SHOP dog that's cool you pet them and
you're like well they're not pet but
their job bags were they were they mean
them now they were nice golden retriever
what as a SHOP dog yeah and then he's
baby whoo
her name was bippy okay and then after
baby we got Veruca who was a Labrador
huh
sounds like a Russian immigrant yeah the
lead singer of a band named after Veruca
from Willy Wonka anything in the house I
had when I was really little like hermit
crab parents are trapped the most the
utley for like [ __ ] five years man I
couldn't kill them I swear I couldn't
kill him and then a snake and a lizard
sneaking you i paged you as a reptilian
lizard
I wouldn't think something was [ __ ]
sick Nate got out never found it Wow
dude I had it my cousin gave me a snake
for my like [ __ ] eighth birthday and
it climbed that's real trash yeah man
we're we're trash it had babies and they
they were like tiny little they look
like a little [ __ ] sperm and they
climbed up out of the cage and my mom
came down in the morning there was like
[ __ ] 500 of these little worms all
over we were all over the asker find him
for like six weeks I'm out I'll tell you
that there's no [ __ ] way I would've
stayed in there couldn't we were upside
down a mouse
snakes or no snakes we couldn't get out
we're Morgan's to the eyeballs over here
I think she refined a couple of times oh
my god all right family you're at
Thanksgiving dinner you guys put out
ketchup at Thanksgiving no okay good
answer
there you go and you see you mentioned
your grandmother grandfather lot so your
mother's I assume that's your mother's
side of the other side of the family
very close very close so you do
everything with them yeah I stayed with
them on the weekends
pretty much all through growing up Wow
they lived in North Bergen which is like
one town over even how old were you
doing this till probably like right
around almost high school necessity or I
like hanging out with Grandma grandpa I
just liked it over there
no [ __ ] I think it was to get my parents
and head off he had doors over there
grandpa takes two hearings a hearing
aids out I get as loud as I want did you
have another set of friends over there
no cuz that's real trashy no I did not
because I had that at my at my aunt's
house because my aunt would babysit me
during the day and they lived in another
neighborhood and I had a couple of
[ __ ] dirtbike friends that knew me
over there too he would come around
every now and there the kid that came
around every day if you were the kid
that came around every now then you were
bad [ __ ] news no opposite man I can
put my family was so nervous about
anything like people like the reason my
grandma told me they never got a pool
mm-hmm was because she was afraid that
if they went on vacation people would
break in mm-hmm swim in the pool drown
and then sue her yeah that's crazy
I remember real free spirit 16 years old
staying at my grandma's for the night
and I got like six o'clock at night go
to I'll be like hey I'm gonna take a
walk I'll be back in a little while and
my grandma blocking the door with her
body line what if there's kids out there
who are up to no good and you get
involved huh I was not dude I involved
like what like I was not allowed to
crime stopper or you start I was not
allowed out as a kid unless I had a
destination and it was people my pet
like
if I want to go to somebody's house when
I was a kid it was two weeks notice
what wait from your mom - yeah so they
all had this fear yes are they Irish no
German they're garbage
two weeks dollars to go to somebody's
house my mom had to see their house
first wow that's real that's a wonder
why you're an inside strong parenting
yeah that's so you even have a lot of
friends growing up in high school I mean
yet people at school but you know so
what was a simple / situation very rare
I think my house [ __ ] doors true
can't get up to no good without any
doors high school sleepovers got all
weird yeah we needed doors what we were
doing just to keep anybody from a good
question give me some give me some
LimeWire and a door I'll be in the guest
room if you need me holy [ __ ] Zach none
of that [ __ ] that's a lot yeah man
that's like [ __ ] did they like
whatever what caused that do you think
just did they have did your mom have any
brothers and sisters my mom had a
brother and a sister now were they so
today have passed our sisters my aunt
and uncle live in the house with my
grandma now okay did they have kids nope
so you were the only kid there was no
cousins my I eat cousins on my dad's
side but you don't [ __ ] with him but
yeah I didn't really see them very much
after I was a certain age when did this
aesthetic come into play for you like
the tally went like was this always or
is this like kind of when you got out on
your own you're like I'm getting the
tattoos the hair the glint like but they
have let you get to that's my question
is like really like I got him Ramon Hawk
towards the end of high school and that
was like you came off very good deal Wow
and yeah I've always like I've always
kind of wanted that look uh-huh
and yeah I just put it I went ape [ __ ]
when I went to college [ __ ] purple
hair ten PSA of course yeah that's what
happens I had a buddy that grew up
saying he wasn't allowed to do anything
ever
we don't think I'll we're sleeping here
party what do you think I can't I gotta
go home I went to college I'm [ __ ]
next you know he's like [ __ ] Zahl my
oxys and [ __ ] he's robbing
banks that's what happens when those
kids are pent up yes I went nuts and
then eventually just became like this
lazy white-trash punk-rock kind of thing
mm-hmm
you're mount cook growing up not well it
was a snack situation free doesn't bean
dip oh I can bean dip can be in depth
what you make it or she would make it oh
there was no I was not allowed in the I
was not allowed in the kitchen area
your mom will make you Fritos and bean
dip what do you mean like what if she
was at work you couldn't go and get a
snack so I would leave things out and
then the rule you don't want my dad
still your look at the POWs plate if my
mom wasn't home under the no door all
meals were to be eaten over the sink or
a garbage can what the [ __ ] yeah right
do you think this Samia says do you
think just [ __ ] you up a little bit
I'm a [ __ ] slob now okay and I can't
control it letting it all hang out hey
I'm disgusting and that is 100% why bean
dip is pretty good though I'll say that
it's trash but it's pretty you heat that
up a little bit of [ __ ] cheddar
cheese we are when we did our podcast I
thought my mom's hot cha-cha-cha oh yeah
Zack case nobody home cooks we have any
foodies the our use of salsa on top of a
chicken baked in the oven served over
Tostitos it was the sour cream sometimes
you walk a bowl we know that's a little
too Mexican wouldn't guacamole as a kid
I've never had [ __ ] cha-cha-cha
chicken no it was like my dad would call
the other day and we talk about somebody
told me that his girlfriend made London
broil and he got him head about it he
was like throw and he and then I was
like but then you had it
how was he good he was you know London
Broyles good I went yeah yeah it's like
not bad he goes I always thought it was
like this gray tasteless meat growing up
on the brother that was that's trash
filet mignon that's not your mom would
make it it would be try I mean no my
family's food was like
the meme of what white people issue are
real the last time we had dinner with my
mom my grandma my mother warned the rest
of the table and I'm not [ __ ] with
you guys watch out the creamy Italian
dressings real spicy what we're creamy a
talent like from the bottle creamy
Italian dressing here mom goes watch out
it's spicy it's got a real kick in it
god that's my family's idea of like
spicy ethnic [ __ ] this rage has got a
kick to it watch out holy [ __ ] what
would take out be like where would you
get to what'd you do take out we do
usually pizza what kind of like local
place yeah like dominoes never Domino's
and now local yeah German soldiers yeah
or sometimes Chinese and then there was
a place a block and a half away called
the land and sea grill and that was a
big one that was like burgers and dogs I
can get down with the land and see girl
yeah I hear you
this is a wild tale done when we did it
on real last podcast you blew my mind I
was like I was not expecting any of any
of those answers and now I came into it
with that mindset of like yeah he's
clean living now I don't know what the
[ __ ] that this is have you ever asked
your mom like yeah why were you like
that or why no cuz she's better yeah so
I don't want to bring it up yeah that's
that's a good point she's not like that
anymore we go to your house right now
she letting me in
she's letting you in before Amin
interesting I brought when I moved to
Brooklyn okay
twelve years ago I had roaches and made
the mistake of telling my family that I
was dealing with that she still brings
it up round this day if I have a
backpack on my arm goes leave it
downstairs like a watches what if he got
bugs in it I want you bring give her
that one yeah I haven't been able to sit
on my mother's couch since high school
lot because I had a pair of pants on
with like buttons on the back and one of
them popped a little hole in her leather
ouch and to this day if I try to sit on
the couch of my mom's house from another
room she'll just come screaming what the
hell kind of pants you got on
oh [ __ ] she runs a tight [ __ ] [ __ ]
now has this effect that you I mean
obviously it's effective but how you cuz
you're married now yeah how you guys
operate your household I'm told I say
sorry a lot but I immediately apologize
I think that's just crowd control no
like yes that's because my dad would fly
off the hinge at any given minute so you
apologize if you want to take a back in
with the Rings well no my problem is I
am I get panic attacks when it's like
time to clean like if the vacuums gone
or anything okay
he's like a dog yeah he's like he's like
a lab she's like I get panic attack II
when it was my wisely cleaning and she
was like why what's wrong it was always
like a high-pressure situation dude I
had the exact opposite I hear a vacuum
cleaner I want to fall asleep I used to
follow my mom around the house when she
had this vacuum cleaning that had like
had like the other part of it than a
hose and then the thing and I would lay
right behind the back of the exhaust
waiting for crumbs it was like a John
Henry situation
no the warm air blowing on me I would
lay my head down and take a little nap I
mean dude you are another kind of [ __ ]
up I don't know man that is [ __ ]
insane but do you guys cook the are you
guys more are you more homey more
inviting a hundred percent but you're
not you're not still eating over the
[ __ ] sink and no now we do meal prep
plans now pretty good okay that's clean
living I'd be great yeah living in
Brooklyn like you don't like I don't
live near a good grocery store mm-hmm
it's like 1012 blocks if I want to go to
like a good one
yeah and dude [ __ ] those those we're
doing the Sun basket right now is that
the day it gets delivered yeah
everything comes to the house it's real
[ __ ] nice it's not money no that's a
little bit of game there's a little bit
of cash yeah and a very far cry from
your situation growing up yeah
whoo okay so I guess there wasn't like
what was what would what would your
typical lunch be what would your mom
said
to school baloney and cheese pickles
pickles
oh you would vocational school any piece
of pickles and mustard is this all on
the sandwich
yeah like pickle pickle chips what'd you
ever get a pickle it's my mom I would
[ __ ] I'd call CPS sent me to school
with a [ __ ] pickle that's crazy
maybe on the side lonely confused when I
was a kid kid Lunchables Wow I know but
we've never really met anybody we've
taught lunch we talked about Lunchables
a lot and we've never actually met
anybody that got them on a steady basis
very steady basis especially once they
brought up the lunchable nachos those
nachos wears terrible and that was a
frequent flavor the little chips like
the size of a dime yeah my buddy Pat
would get those all the terrible now I
imagine that was a pretty big temptation
for you having those stacked up in the
fridge but I then you weren't allowed to
go near more no not allowed near
anything not allowed to bring food for
like if I had leftovers from a
restaurant mm-hmm and I didn't tell my
mom and I put it in the fridge that
would be like a meltdown like no putting
anything new in the fridge everything
was very controlled
what the [ __ ] there might be a better CD
a bit yusei's enticed that since it did
if I couldn't go into my fridge and
[ __ ] root around and drink from the
can taste you weren't allowed fixing the
container string from the toilet god no
oh I'll tell you so I used in my living
room next to the TV was I don't know
what it was it was just a hole in the
carpeting and I never knew what it was
but whenever my mom would go in the
shower I would go run and try to sneak a
stack like a granola bar anything and
then if my mom was getting out of shower
and I wasn't done with it yet there was
just a hole in the living room and I
would shove it down the hole and I found
out that it would went in of course
because we're the second floor it was
above my dad shop and one day there was
a storm and they got wet and the thing
collapsed and just years of half-eaten
food those bars as yet
like popcorn pop secret boys just came
flooding into my Pig welder on Jesus
it's raining gushers that's sad man that
sucks
or even just the wrapper because I
couldn't put the wrapper in the garbage
yeah because that's trace evidence
that's like the Great Santini
it's [ __ ] that's a complete I do all
my house was [ __ ] wine Olsen my mom
would box like variety packs like 224
packs like Pringle or like the like
Doritos he [ __ ] like and she would try
to hide them where the pots and pans
where I'm like you dumb broad I see that
coming from a mile away
question you gotta put them under your
bed everything I'm gonna stop you think
I'm not gonna you think I'm just gonna
check the pantry and keep it moving
yeah when you guys know I'm in the
basement and you had a bag like a big
bag of chips for the family sure were
you allowed to eat from the bag or did
it have to go in a bowl with a paper
towel in it we were a bag that we would
do the paper towel if company was over
you would do that but you pour it into a
container okay we're still from the bag
we had yeah we ate and as I could have
[ __ ] put him on my nuts she wouldn't
get here it was wide open of the Foley
well we used to use the clips clips
first came out the chip clips yeah but
they're all with their lights there's
they're few and far between there was
only like one of them we had five bags
of chips if you'd have to like wrap a
rubber band around it or enclosed but
there was none of that none of that [ __ ]
would there be a bag of chips in the
house there would be a bag of chips but
it was asked goes in a ball with a paper
towel and my my spotless
yo yeah big time the thing i don't like
about the bowl is that you're limited
yeah Nazi regime what do you mean it's
guys behind enemy lines and then on my
own absolute disaster sure sure yeah New
York with the [ __ ] stone's throw away
from a bodega and a [ __ ] chopped
cheese and a [ __ ] Arizona iced tea
come on yeah whatever the kid but
I literally the first date I had with my
wife I got her to come back home with me
and I had to throw out three Gatorades
full of piss Jesus that was in my just
Gatorade bottles full of pissed that
we're in my room that I hadn't touched I
live with someone who did that and when
you would leave it in there for a long
time it ferments oh Jesus that smell
uh-huh
that is [ __ ] wild you getting all
this holy [ __ ]
did you know any of this Dylan I I did
not Louis Gomez he's never heard me
speak before was the bathroom wide it
was I lived with a bunch of roommates at
the time and they lived with their
chicks so the bathroom was always
[ __ ] and occupied at that time so I
always just would get out of unions and
first try if there was somebody in there
I'm pissing in the Gatorade bottle I
have done that a couple times I lived in
quite a couple of times yeah but when
you're stuck turnpike no I mean I've
done it I've done it in my apartment
when you're like hand-up there's people
in the bedroom and I got you can't hold
you a little Winky until well I finally
trying to go back to bed or I hear like
you're one of the [ __ ] goobers got in
the shower so that's no well you gotta
piss in the middle of the night that
sucks
yeah no I get it cuz you never have to
kinda pass in the middle of the night
yeah not like oh I can wait it's yeah
it's [ __ ] Dean Bolander going Miller
night you're stumbling around stop and
get a snack
all right um this is [ __ ] nuts Jesus
Christ when you guys did you do like
family vacations yeah where Jeffrey
would you ever go to a wax museum where
would you guys hide out together
under what floorboards did you hang out
the vacations I remember well
remember when you bongsam out oh the
ones that I like stick out is like
really good ones okay Alaskan cruise
Alanis classy
rough combination of words tough Alaskan
that's what I'm saying
but Alaska's nice beautiful there
wilderness are in touch with their weed
attention lorries [ __ ] to get there so
it's a little bit of cage now who are we
talking about on this trip with your
grandma I'm a grandpa go with you my
grandpa passed away when I was in like
third fourth grade
oh but grandma would come to everything
yes of course
alright that also explains maybe your
grandmother's over overprotectiveness
there okay so two cruises one was the
last one was like Florida area and this
one your parents are still together yes
so what date when they would go on these
cruises because you like was it
different than the house like could you
eat whatever you want what they have
drinks and mix and mingle with my dad
sober my whole life would they interact
with other people though fifty-fifty we
would do this what we do they would take
my grandma and a lot of times my mom and
dad would go do [ __ ] and me and grandma
would be out for the day on vacation so
like she went on vacation but he's
pretty much saddled with me hmm
not bad that's pretty fun I'll give it I
tell you best vacation yeah yeah you're
gonna this this is such a good big dude
I I legitimately want to go back alright
the biggest mall in the world in
Edmonton Alberta Canada
it's a city it's got the amusement park
a full water park with a wave pool to
weigh in Annie's pretzels like indoor
lake with a pirate ship
it's a city okay and crash is what it is
perfect three different like movie
complexes we went for a week in the
hotel in the mall that's a lot of wok
and roll I'll tell you that have been
cleaning up like the samples even if I
go to Orlando I walk around downtown a
little better you don't stay at Disney
that was the best vacation was it
actually you stayed in the mall you
lived in the mall there's there's
apartment complexes in it for the people
that work there you can't walk the thing
in a day are you from the future
this sounds like a dystopian it would do
it was literally like it was the middle
of winter we went to Canada for it
so outside is like [ __ ] Hoff right
okay you're inside perfect like 76
everywhere you go he's got [ __ ]
some theologians ink on his nose it's
great it was for the best
holy [ __ ] when was the last time you
were out of water park was that it no I
think I did one probably ten years ago
shirt on shirt off shut off shirt on
yeah he doesn't pay me one for qualms
yeah I wore my shirt in the pool once in
like fifth grade and took it off halfway
through because I thought it was it was
lamer to be a guy way shirt on to be a
fat guy to pull of course under floors
and this is a [ __ ] how do your
parents know about the mall City to go
on saw it on TV on like the Travel
Channel oh you're paying out of some
dirtbag shift my mom ever tried to take
me to a [ __ ] mall for a week I mean I
can see it it sounds pretty cool but
just the whole to know about it that's
like a place you come across when you're
on your way somewhere else I'll stop in
here holy [ __ ] there's [ __ ] there's a
lake in the middle of in the middle of a
scoffs do they was [ __ ] wild
damn man also if you have to take a
passport to go to the [ __ ] mall
that's [ __ ] guard you're going to
another country you go to [ __ ]
anywhere
Toronto [ __ ] anywhere you want to go
how do you feel the mall that say this
is all created to zac amico that we all
know and love yeah I always feel like
even the things I regret
probably wouldn't be me without them so
well of course we're all built towards
of course of course man this is like a
[ __ ] are you garbage right you said
this would be a thing and I did some
crazy [ __ ] this actlly
what was the thing you told me about
living in a motel for a year or hotel
for a year oh no the funeral home you
lived in a funeral home you in a row
home yes or the first big movie I worked
on was actually two movies we shot them
back-to-back they're called return to
Newcomb High one until they were sequel
to an 80s movie called the class of nuke
em high and we went out and we needed to
find and I was like the first wave of
people that went out we shot it in
Niagara Falls New York which is a
[ __ ] dude Niagara is Troy's vacation
at a mall
that's like the South of France we
needed a city that looked like it had
already been destroyed and we had to do
no art direction and me the producer and
his assistant go out and like the film
Commission's kind of working with us
trying to help us find space and we
needed an office for the movie a living
situation for 80 people and a special
effects studio and this real estate
agent in the town wanted to be a movie
producer mm-hmm and he was like this big
dr. Phil's a big market up there here he
wanted he wanted to get into film and
they actually shoot a lot of movies of
Buffalo now and he's I got the perfect
place for you and it was an abandoned
funeral home ah [ __ ] huge and we turned
the top half at through our living space
and are earned the fine turned like
Fremont got it no we got it
you're easing out see you raped up the
floors repainted everything got a
certificate of occupancy uh-huh for I
think like 20 people and we had 80
people move in I like Harry whispered
that like that was gonna be this real
trash breaking an occupancy level and we
were sleepin elbow - oh man you wouldn't
have done all this if it wasn't for how
you grew up you agree with that 100%
yeah if you went to like private school
like a good you know like parents that
stayed together if you could go get a
granola bar without getting your [ __ ]
face slapped yeah yeah then we have the
special effects workshop downstairs
because it had a morgue where drains in
the floor so that's where we did all the
special effects because anything got on
the floor just drained right now talk
about the heebie-jeebies yeah I mean
like so much that we went to work it's
gonna get you we went to work on another
movie for another company and we called
the guy who rented the funeral home
again for just 20 of us because we
missed it cuz you missed it because it
was like camp dude it was so fun I'm
gonna have a [ __ ] smoke walk around
the block I don't know I can't get a
read on this [ __ ] guy the mall the
[ __ ] you know sneak and kudos it's a
lot was the last time use a Coinstar
machine
see there you go oh I would have guessed
today no I want to say probably six
seven years ago was it for cash or just
cuz you had some change laying around I
needed money yeah the money for the
morgue yeah I needed a new urn yeah I
definitely needed money and I there was
one a few blocks away from me and I did
the Coinstar
yeah okay have you ever been to a Red
Lobster
within the Addams Family house yeah yeah
he dated Wednesday for a couple of years
took her there to the Red Lobster I tell
you what you say what you want about Red
Lobster but when you got a [ __ ]
cheddar biscuit sitting in front of you
you don't have a care in the world
no better place for a community college
graduation party oh that's real trashy
bobster hole same parent company is
Olive Garden discount overlap yes I used
to work at Macy's and I could go to
Bloomingdale's and get them percent
though what your beak alright let's do
some of the some of the standards uh
would you have as a kid you're sat down
for dinner would you have milk with
dinner no okay good he wouldn't get
dinner where would you keep the ketchup
after it was opened as a kid and now
fridge fridge okay do you currently have
any ketchup packets in your refrigerator
right now 100% that is duck sauce hot
mustard yeah all in one plastic bag oh
that's real garbage [ __ ] real yeah
you're trying to keep a clue and some
can see finger looking good sauce Oh
what about the wipes you got the wipes
in there too little lemon wipes no but
there are some currently on my coffee
table because we had wings last week I
used to want to eat those and I was a
kid they smell so good
the lemon wipes know things you wipe
your little fingers yeah that was a big
deal no I just talked to you about
you're a fan of the pre sliced pepperoni
from the company Hormel correct I'm
familiar they put the thing it what's
the preservative packet they put in
there yeah
do that with electronics I've seen
things in beef jerky yeah what is it
it's some kind of I thought it was air
freshener or something I put it in the
car it's good coffee put that in the cup
of tea I don't it does something I
almost it's so weird you said I almost
ate one like two days ago cuz I'm on the
keto and I've been [ __ ] crushing
pepperoni slices
qureshi yeah I don't think that's gonna
do it ketchup in the fridge maple syrup
in the cabinet
yeah right it's hard to get a read on
this my big hot sauce guy right I just
ordered a six pack of chili of all the
different Cholula but I love I love me
some hot sauce I probably had eight
different hot sauces in the fridge right
now
what was the cable situation growing up
what would your mom get yeah Comcast did
you have any 40 mm lah no no HBO or
anything like that they were tight with
a buck yeah yeah just regular cable and
then I don't have cable now I just have
a hat March it yeah yeah do a free range
the TV the remote watch this watch that
whatever you want it was that restricted
to dependent if I was it was during the
day and no one was watching my mom had
soaps in the middle of the day just by
the cover of night yeah
oh no no TV at night no doors no doors
he couldn't watch TV no TV no 18 no me
laughter I mean I mean after the parents
were 50 watch 18 he's mighty yeah if my
mom was ready for bed no TV that [ __ ]
was out no doors socks lighting lights
out can't can't keep my lights on and
read because the lights no doors lights
out that was like military [ __ ] to me if
my mom tried to pull some lights out
business yeah hit the [ __ ] breakable
if you have it you didn't shoot up that
mall when you laughing I'll be honest
with you man
talk about a coup something else a very
special episode of are you garbage oh
man I think I'm done yeah
I did have one but I mean who even cares
at this point have you ever sold
anything at a flea market
I sold no my guy was in the bridge the
video okay when I was a kid my aunt's
best friend Laurie ran up to my tie
remember this so clearly ran up to my
aunt at the flea market to say how cheap
the condoms were all my and she was
buying boxes of condoms from not even a
table at the flea market you know the
side part of the flea market or it's
just cardboard boxes on the ground or
and everything's a buck the guy who
couldn't get a table yeah yeah she was
buying condoms from him and I remember
her having a kid the next year of course
dude what was her name again
[Laughter]
zac amico kevin thoughts headache i
don't know
garbage yeah for sure garbage I mean
he's got should be another word for it
no I don't know what the [ __ ] it is I
don't have it I refuse rhythms I can't
believe I can't believe you're not
weirder I'm not gonna lie not that you
are weird but I'm just saying like I
said I gave I yeah sorry [ __ ] minds
blown I know I think you were like you
had a good base right you had a good
base for like maybe let's call it I
don't know 10 years or something and
then [ __ ] went haywire you know and like
yeah because all the stuff with your
parents other than the weird vacations
that training should have led you to not
be garbage right like it was [ __ ] up
when you were experiencing but you know
you think you were super neat super tidy
super this super that dad was a business
owner real estate bubble up about you
know do you think you're garbage I think
I have garbage tendencies okay you know
yeah we all I mean in the way that like
you know I love GG Allin sure yeah yeah
there's - [ __ ] GG Allin there's -
that's from like a skate video from like
the thousands there's - you can have two
completely separate zac amico stories it
can be zac amico and why you grad who
works in [ __ ] movie production right
[ __ ] you know all
[ __ ] and then you could just have like
the [ __ ] sneakin snags and I know man
I don't [ __ ] know and then getting
caught for ya going to the mole oh the
caper off no doors crews in Alaska real
ass can cruise oh you had a Cornelia
Marie this [ __ ] crab fishing boat he
was a goose of greenhorns this guy's
whale hunting I can I was College oh
holy [ __ ] zac amico hundred percent
garbage but like you said garbage
tendencies a very [ __ ] interesting
tale and i don't know if anybody knew
that whole backstory well that was i was
[ __ ] something else
thank you feel like we just got like a
15 hour deposition I gotta call my
[ __ ] life I don't know what's going on
is there anything you want to folks out
there to know that they might not yeah
just check me out on Instagram at SAC is
a not funny
check out my shows acting because
midnight spook show every Friday at
midnight here on gas and catalyst
wrestling 11:00 a.m. on Saturdays here
on gas and if anybody's in the
Pennsylvania area I will be in the
Mahoning drive-in theater on August 7th
and 8th for two full days of Troma
movies where I'll be hosting doing a
live podcast and hanging out for I think
two straight games watch a movie should
be really fun nice very nice Kippy what
do you got at Kevin Ryan comedy on all
social media also guys the support of
this podcast has been [ __ ] awesome
unbeliev I mean it's it's it's wild all
the [ __ ] realized podcast fans all
the [ __ ] Legion of skanks fans you
got all the everybody from the gasps
digital family has been [ __ ] awesome
I was like I said we were currently
still in the top 200 we want to keep
moving up so please rate review
subscribe share with a friend also full
video available on YouTube you can
subscribe there as well thank you so
much absolutely and guys a shout out to
everybody that did do reviews this week
for the belly-flop video it's been so
fun going back one throw with you guys
and we'd love these and we will we'll
see you next time
are you garbage please